so the day that everyone seems to be
waiting for is finally here
MD is officially launching their rx 5000
series GPUs and boy has it been an
interesting few weeks you see this all
started at e3 when AMD showed off their
shiny new Navi GPUs particularly the rx
5000 series and then team green had to
respond with their r-tx super cards that
sort of set a benchmark as to what these
cards are kind of competing with just a
couple days ago before this launch aim D
throw an interesting curveball a test
with price cuts on these new GPUs at
launch this is just a typical aim the
thing I'm not really surprised but now
after more than a year of rumors we can
finally talk about how the RX 5700 XD
and the 5700 perform in benchmarks are
they actually worth buying over the
Arctic super cards that team green
launched just last week to be honest
with you a lot of this video had to be
redone just because of AMD's new lower
prices on these graphics cards so let's
talk about that right after a quick word
from our sponsor looking for a solid
board to pair your 9 gen CPU the azrog Z
390 Taichi gets it right with robust vrm
designs for extreme overclocking a 12
phase power design for smooth power
delivery dual band Wi-Fi 3m 2 slots and
reinforced PCI connectors learn more
about it down below alright so if you
want a bit more information about these
new GPUs specifically with the
architecture you can actually check out
our explain video right over here but in
this video I'm gonna be focusing a lot
more on the performance benchmarks and
not really get into the other stuff and
also since a lot of you guys have been
asking I'll make sure to leave
timestamps in the description down below
so let's do a quick spec recap on both
of these new GPUs so they're based off
the Navi 10 core and use a seven
nanometer manufacturing process the RX
5,700 XD will have 2560 stream
processors eight gigabytes of gddr3 with
448 gigabytes per second of bandwidth
aboard power of 225 watts and now a
lower price of $400 u.s. its base and
game frequencies are 1605 megahertz and
1750 5 megahertz respectively the RX
5700 gets cut down to a little over
2,000 stream processors and
frequencies which lowers voice hour to
about 180 watts it still gets eight
gigabytes of gddr3 hundred and fifty
dollars us now about that new pricing
it's really made things interesting
because after seeing Helen videos rth
supercars perform
I think AMD might have come to a
realization that they priced these new
GPUs a little too high especially if you
consider when those new RT X super cards
come with two free games so this is how
things line up right now the rx 2700 XT
is a whole hundred dollars cheaper than
the RT X xx semi super making it the
exact same price as the RT X 2060 super
the arcs fifty seven hundreds price is
about the same as the RT X 2060 another
thing a lot of people have brought up is
how used gtx 980ti cards cost around
300-400 dollars these days I'd be a bit
worried of getting one that's been
abused in countless hours of
cryptocurrency mining but yeah that's
another option if you're willing to take
the risk let's take a look at the cards
to see what you're getting since at
launch there won't be any custom designs
which is unfortunate those will be
available to buy a month or more
afterwards starting with the 5700 XT
it's one good-looking graphics card with
a swooping heatsink shroud that almost
looks dented but that design is supposed
to increase internal airflow and lower
the amount of noise to flipping the card
around there's a full-coverage backplate
that uses the same cool rib design as
the top shroud but this time it's broken
up by a smooth area along with a red
strip one of our concerns with these
blower style cards is that they're
always fighting for air flow but the RX
5700 x DS back edge is actually pretty
open which should increase the amount of
air it can draw in but personally my
favorite angle of this card is from the
edge which has the glowing Radeon logo
it looks clean and really well done and
that's where the eight plus six pen
power connectors are for output AMD has
kept it pretty simple with three
DisplayPort 1.4 B connectors and a
single HDMI 2.0 B on both cards now by
comparison to the XT the RX 5700 is
almost boring basically the entire
shroud is a uniform gray with the red
Radeon text and a small amount of silver
around the
honestly I think aim D should have added
a back plate here since the r-tx 2060
and the r-tx 2060 super founders
editions have cool-looking back plates
this just looks cheap in my opinion and
another big concern is that aim these
designers chose to close the back edge
which kills airflow this is just another
opposition since adding a secondary
intake area should have been a
no-brainer wrapping things up the power
connectors are identical to the 5,700 XT
with an 8 plus 6 pin layout now looking
at these cards it's pretty easy to be
concerned about acoustic performance
especially since blowers tell coolers
are always louder than downdraft coolers
like these so let's take a listen to all
of these GPUs at load since during idle
scenarios all of them are super quiet
so it's obvious that the RX cards are
lot louder than the r-tx super series
but this is all fan noise luckily there
wasn't any coil whine on the AMD GPUs
which is certainly good news but I do
want to mention that the coil one on the
r-tx 2060 super certainly did influence
its results which is just too bad I also
want to quickly look at power
consumption because AMD has made a lot
of progress with their seven nanometer
manufacturing process but is it enough
so this is actually pretty interesting
since it looks like be 5700 series has
nearly closed the gap but that isn't
necessarily good news
remember Nvidia is still on 12 nanometer
and it took a super-efficient 790 meter
process for AMD to draw even at least
this time anyone who buys a Radeon card
won't have to worry about super high
power draw so I think it's time to talk
about how these cards stack up but I'm
gonna start things a little bit
differently this time starting with the
overall performance benchmark list and
if you want to know how we acquired
those numbers the individual game
performance will follow right afterwards
so this is what things look like after a
dozen of games being tested and you can
actually see why AMD reduced their
prices you'll see in the next few
minutes that knobby's performance is
very strong against invidious r-tx 2070
and the 2060 but the Super Series is
very different in raw numbers the RX
5700 XT loses by about 12% overall to
the r-tx 2070 super and the RX 5700 sits
right in between the RT x 2060 and the
RT x 2060 super there is really nothing
to complain about here since all of
these are really strong numbers but hold
on when it comes to raw value AMD
actually leads by a pretty big margin
the RX 5700 x DS new $400 price causes
it to just dominate the $500 RT x 2070
super even the RX 5700 looks pretty good
against the RT x 2060 super I mean it
doesn't offer more performance but it
does cost a whole 50 dollars less while
also beating the vanilla RT X 2060 by
about 7% like I said in the RT x super
review the pricing of these two RT x 20
60 cards is just way too high right now
also guys do keep in mind that the GTX
TI provides almost similar performance
to the r-tx 2080 so if you can find that
GPU for $400 or less it would blow any
of these cards right out of the water
but as I mentioned earlier be aware of
the mining cards in the used market so
where does this leave the rx 5,700 XD
and the rx 3700 well other than the
average frame rates I already mentioned
during testing we also notice that their
lower 1% frame rates were all over the
place in some games like Battlefield 5
they easily beat the Nvidia cars but in
some really popular titles like
fortnight pop G and Total War they
really liked pretty far behind
so obviously consistency is still an
issue for AMD so the big question is
whether or not if you should buy the rx
5700 series over GeForce r-tx and the
answer to that really depends on what
you think of invidious features like
rate racing DL SS and content adaptive
shading you see if you only care about
standard game rendering the arcs
57-hundred xt is a better buy than the
RT x 2070 super and the same can be said
about the rx 5700 versus the RT X 2060
super but this is important you can't
just ignore what Nvidia has to offer
especially since a lot of these games
are including waitressing elements and
performance is improving so that does
count for something so there you guys
have it and I certainly think Amy's on
the right track it's just that they have
a lot of catching up to do but I really
want to know thoughts about all of this
do you still think these cards are too
expensive or is there one that you look
into are there any other games or tests
that you'd like us to run definitely let
us know in the comments down below I'm
you go with hurricane axe thank you so
much for watching make sure to check out
certain relevant content over here
subscribe for some cool content coming
the pipeline I'm sliding off and I'll
see you guys in the next one